I learned that man they will pray for
you without praying for you it's not
like this getting on their knees and but
I know they all want me to win because
if they if I win they win they win and
they truly know that so it's like they
all get the ego out of the way they that
and when a woman prayer is with you man
like I tell people a woman got two
vaginas she got the regular vagina and
that spiritual
vagina we know which one you came in all
the time I went for that spiritual
vagina I used I when I was young I used
to go for the phys vagina but man you
messing around catch a bacteria fish
but that that physical vagina is
controlled by her but that spiritual
vagina is controlled by God it's her
prayer